a lot of times people think of
turbulence as the wind hitting the nose
this is captain stuart walker after more
than 30 years of flying
he knows a lot about turbulence and
there's more than one type
we've actually got the winds coming from
all different directions of the airplane
he's here to explain the main types of
turbulence how they impact your flight
and what he and you can do to get the
smoothest ride
there's many types of turbulence that
you can find out
when we're flying but the four main
types are clear turbulence
thermal turbulence mechanical turbulence
and wake turbulence
clear turbines is exactly that it's
clear its air is turbulent
meaning it may look clear outside your
window then
the plane starts to shake ideally if
we're
traveling we've got a nice tailwind and
if we've got the jet
on our tail we might have 150 knots of
extra
ground speed just because of that
tailwind but if the
jet stream veers off i'm going to lose
some of that
tailwind and as i do i change the
dynamics of the airplane
and basically i can get a rocking motion
or
i can get a large pitch up if it's a
sheer from another
crossing wind so what's happening here
has a lot to do with jet streams
those invisible rivers of air that
encircle the globe and when they
are bent and turned they create shears
in the air
and those pockets of shear are where
we're finding that clear
turbulence we've got 150 knots off the
left wing and all of a sudden it's
shifting to a tail when we're expecting
that it's probably going to have a
little bit of a shear
but clear air turbulence is tough to
predict walker says
pilots rely on modeling graphical
displays on board
and information from dispatchers to try
to avoid turbulent areas
the good news about clear turbulence
though is it
typically does not last but a couple
thousand feet so if we just descend a
couple thousand or climb a couple
thousand
we can usually fly out of some of that
rough air
[Music]
thermal turbulence is just the opposite
of clear air turbulence we can see it
that's because it's caused by rising
warm air or thermals which can create
clouds
cumulonimbus clouds the kind that carry
thunderstorms are the biggest concern
typically planes fly over most of the
weather but clouds can sometimes
tower up into a plane's cruising
altitude so if our aircraft encountered
for some reason flew into an area
that had those those towering clouds
what we would expect is we've got a lot
of those vertical shafts either coming
up or down
and so we're going to get some pretty
violent movement on our aircraft
not only that but we might have those
hailstones that might damage the
aircraft or our engines so
for that reason it's always best to turn
around
and fly around the weather but
dispatchers try to stop the scenario
before it even happens by giving pilots
a detailed flight plan
which contains in at a route that should
avoid these weather systems
when i get the flight plan i've got some
of the same tools
in my cockpit when the weather changes
and moves and
shifts i get the real-time information
when i get that
i'm able to make much better decisions
about my route of flight or my altitude
but don't worry if you fly through
clouds on your next flight
i get a lot of people sometimes ask do
you just avoid all the clouds
and the answer is no when we have nice
strata clouds
those clouds if we fly through those you
probably wouldn't even notice
mechanical turbulence has kind of a
funny name but it's exactly that there's
something mechanically
in the way of that wind that's blowing
down the lower altitudes it might be
trees it might be buildings might be
hills
up at higher altitudes it could be
something a lot more than just the trees
and the hills
it could be the rocky mountains the
rockies can create what's called
mountain wave it happens when air blows
over the mountains and falls down the
other side
creating rotors of air that are then
carried up into the jet stream
sometimes hundreds of miles from the
mountains if we're flying
and we've got the rockies over here and
we've got that strong wind
with those rotors as they come up and
they
impact my aircraft sometimes i'm going
to see an increasing performance and
then a decreasing performance of the
aircraft
it might cause my aircraft to pitch up
slightly and then back down
typically they're not as violent if i'm
hitting them head-on
but if i'm hitting them from the side
sometimes it can give you a good rocking
motion
to try to avoid these situations walker
says he communicates with air traffic
control to learn of any reports of
mountain wave before entering
mountainous airspace
as a pilot we're always concerned about
mountain wave because just like clear
air turbulence it can just
all of a sudden be there and not there
but if we can fly
at a lower altitude we can avoid some of
those rotors or we can sometimes fly
above those out
that altitude avoid them as well
wake turbulence is something that we
encounter when we come in for landing
is something that comes naturally off of
our wings
is a byproduct of the lift on the wings
as
that uh airflow directs the wind
over and around off the wingtip we get
these vortices that come
off the wing on both wings and so you
can actually see them trailing off at
times
think of it like the wake off of a boat
the vortices of air coming off the
plane's wings
tend to dissipate out from the aircraft
if we're following too closely behind
another aircraft
that wake instead of falling and
dissipating down here
it stays active for a couple minutes and
it can be blown back into
our course so if we're the aircraft
following
we might encounter that wake turbulence
and we get basically a little bit of a
rocking
how much rocking depends on the plane in
front typically larger aircraft produce
more weight
still this doesn't worry walker much the
good news about wake turbulence
is that all we have to do is adjust a
couple you know 50 feet
a little bit left or right and we're out
of it though pilots are working to keep
the plane flying smoothly
walker does have a few tips for flyers
looking for the calmness ride
first where you sit if you are one of
those that are fearful of turbulence
you know that actually sitting over the
wing maybe further to the forward part
of the cabin
is going to be a slightly better ride
than the back of the bus
second when you fly maybe book it in the
morning
typically in the morning you don't have
quite the heating
and you don't have that thermal
turbulence that we were talking about
and
as every pre-flight announcement says
keep your seat belt fastened
you never know when you may experience
rough air
[Music]